all right Skye
Skye where'd you grow up where are you
from originally
um Riverside Moreno Valley
tell me about your family growing up uh
well my family like white
so like
um
my mom was kind of strict like growing
up and stuff your mom was right start
growing up yeah
um she does she don't like what I do
but
and then my grandparents don't like what
I do but like I'm like a Grandpa's girl
so like
my grandpa still loves me and [__]
but
um yeah yeah just go back to your
childhood what was your how would you
describe your childhood
oh it was pretty good I mean it was good
my mom my mom was a good mom no abuse
nothing like that
um yeah but like but like from like
Mom's boyfriends and stuff
but like it wasn't bad like it was not
bad I made the most of it what kind of
girl were you in high school
um I was popular
like I had a lot of friends everybody
liked me
how old are you now 21 21.
how long you've been doing this kind of
work
three years going on for like three and
a half how'd you get into it
um my homegirl actually
we started off in like poker games and
like online
and um at the strip club
yeah now you're on Figueroa Street yeah
but it's not bad
are you are you doing this with a uh
with the dude or on your own no well
myself you're by yourself yeah
that's hard to do on fig right
kind of but like you just have to know
the places like to be and you can't act
like you're alone
you have to act like you have a pimp
act like you owe somebody yeah yeah
do you have kids
yes I have one you have one yeah and who
where is he or she
um with my baby daddy's mom
and that's where I'm gonna do
I'm sorry Brenda Glendale yeah okay
so where do you live now
um
you have an apartment Gardena no I live
in like
like with like my people but like in a
back house like all right like you're
staying with family or something
um something like that okay not blood
but family yeah
and tell me about working uh the streets
is that uh
what are the ups and downsides of that
I mean there's downsides you know it's
not
the safest thing in the world have you
had things happen to you yeah
but like
I've learned from them and I know like
what things to avoid and what not stuff
not to do
it doesn't scare you away from doing it
no
I mean there's been times where I was
kind of scared like for a few days you
know like
I I was scared like
a lot of people that shouldn't have
scared me I'd be like oh I don't know
just because of the incident but
but besides that no not really
tell me about the the your typical
customer down there hunt today is it
most of them are Mexican
yeah
yeah muscle relaxant lately I've been
getting more white Deuce yeah and you
guys will go off to a hotel
sometimes car car dates
um if they have like more money then
I'll do a room
and you uh
her drugs are part of your life or no
they used to be they used to be yeah
but not no more
what do you used to use
um like the m30s like the pills
so it means fentanyl
yeah
if they're on the street
and you'll work what what hours
typically
um
like
I'm more used to working like night
shift because I like sleeping during the
day
because it's hot outside for me but I'm
also anemic so like like the night time
because so like I split it up between
like daytime and night time
how much money will you make in a day
typically like a thousand
a thousand a day sometimes less if it's
slow but yeah but but that's pretty good
money for somebody that's not giving it
away to to a pimp and not spending on
drugs
I mean I buy weed and stuff
what do you do with your money
um well I put some away from my son and
then I'm trying to like start my
business and stuff so but business are
you looking to start oh man well I went
to school for cosmetology so like I'm
trying to start my laundry business and
my nail business hmm
you're thinking you're thinking of your
future yeah I'm trying to like invest in
assets like
selling dogs or buying cars and selling
them or buying houses flipping them I'm
trying to do real estate
are you
thinking of romantic relationships now
or when you're doing this kind of work
you just put that aside no not really
it's hard it's hard to have a
relationship while you do this kind of
work I would think yeah
I don't really like want one I'll look
for that
what have you learned about men from
doing this kind of work
but there's also bad ones
but it's it's a whole part of the game
that's why it's called the game
is there something else you want to do
with your life
when I was younger I wanted to be a
dentist but like
you know how did this become your
your main way was it because you had a
child
that and like because
like my family kicked me out and stuff
and like I was the middle child so I was
like kind of like
you know like not the forgotten one but
like
I feel like my family didn't like me
type type stuff so like I don't know but
I got kicked out when I was like 17. are
you the black sheep of your family kind
of yeah yeah
and your family knows you're doing this
yeah well not really like my mom she
knows but like
she's not cool there like there's been
times where I've been in a restaurant
while um my mom's like you [__] old men
for money yeah
loud but
like try to embarrass me but like
she knows like I'm doing it to survive
and I'm doing good I'm not doing bad so
but she but like now my family thinks
I'm a stripper and like
because I don't I don't want them to
think that like
yeah
because my mom's seen a video of me on
Facebook
oh really yeah
she was like why are you out there
is this a lonely lifestyle for you
not really no yeah
I get to have fun
travel
you travel sometimes where will you go
[Music]
been to New York
um Miami for work is this gonna work
Oregon
Arizona Vegas
why do you travel
as opposed to just staying on because
who wants to stay on fake their whole
life
I'm trying to do something more than
that
what does this kind of work do to your
self-esteem when you have all these guys
like
driving by telling you you're beautiful
I'm sure and and I mean I already have
eyes I've seen I'm not like
like I like I love myself so you're
pretty confident yeah
what is the hardest part of this
lifestyle for you
the I've been to have sex every day
yeah but you don't really have to every
day if you know how to use your mouth
but
but you do like at the same time
what would you say is the most
misunderstood thing about girls that do
this kind of work
[Music]
well some people think we're just like
toys but like
but also like
people on the outside
that aren't on the inside like they seem
bad in it but like
it's really not that bad like
like most of these girls they're not
like forced to do nothing you know what
I mean
not everyone not every girl's been
trafficked and all that yeah and most of
them aren't most of them
do it by choice so
do you think you're addicted to the fast
money though
yes
yeah it's gonna be hard for you to put
down a thousand dollars a day
um I mean I'm not going to I'm trying to
get rid of that
[Music]
dear friends no
no I don't like I don't talk to females
like
I'm not really like I really have no
homegirls
what advice would you give to a girl
who's thinking about doing this kind of
work
um just be wise
on what you on what you're doing and
like always thankful for you do
something
because your actions could get you in
trouble
were there mistakes you made early on
getting into this game
yeah like like what kind of mistakes do
you make
just stuff that I shouldn't have done
because I could have been a lot farther
than now like
than I am now
are there guys will try to pick you up
and you'll
try you'll just walk away or avoid the
interaction
well yeah like I could feel something my
stomach if something if someone's not
right like I won't do it if I have any
like that feeling
well other than that
I'll do it but like I've had some
situations where it backfired on me but
but for the most part I've been pretty
safe
Sky what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
so stay humble and to like
to not let the worst like bring you down
because
Sun's always going to shine again
there's always this tomorrow you know
to make sure all right Skye thank you so
much for sharing your story
be safe out there yeah thank you